[Music]
if you wanted to train your muscles to
be stronger
what would you do would you practice
lifting a one kilo weight
or a five kilo weight the five kilo
weight
right what if you wanted to be a faster
runner would you sprint for one second
or 30 seconds
30 seconds of course you likely knew the
answers to these
without thinking not because you're a
world class athlete
although maybe you are but more likely
because you understand that the way you
practice
something dictates the results you get
from that practice
that's not to say that you need to
always do the hardest thing
every single time if you want to gain
muscle you'd be well served by lifting
5 kilo weights but you would not get
much benefit from trying to live to your
entire house
different types of engagement are
appropriate for different circumstances
your brain works in exactly the same way
the way you engage in a mental skill has
a profound
impact on how your proficiency in that
skill
develops over time that's why i divide
my language learning activities between
three levels of engagement passive
active and proactive these
three engagement levels can be applied
to each of the four
major language skills reading writing
listening
and speaking let's consider reading
first when you're reading passively
you're just reading as you normally
would in your mother tongue
just you and the book reading
continuously until you stop
when you read actively you read like
normal but
as you read you take notes you engage
with the text
maybe you read out loud or scribble
useful vocab words in the margins
of every page when you read proactively
you do all of the above but take it to
the next level
you prioritize active reading and make
it happen regularly
you schedule time in your day to get
reading done you have a special notebook
dedicated to all of your favorite and
most useful words and phrases
you not only read with intent but you
review what you read with intent as well
next comes listening passive listening
is what you'd probably do with a podcast
in your target language during your
commute
or while washing the dishes for example
you have it on in the background and
your attention
fades in and out it's just there and
it's not even what you're mainly focused
on
you definitely absorb some of it but not
most of it
let alone all of it active listening is
listening with your full focus
maybe you're seated at your desk as i'm
doing right now with your headphones in
or you're outside in a park bench
enjoying the breeze
whatever you're doing your main goal is
to process the speech that's currently
being
piped into your ears that means the
dialogue of a movie the conversation in
a tv talk show
the lyrics of a song you name it when
you listen
proactively though you do all of the
above
but again you take it to the next level
you don't just listen to audio you
follow along with the printed transcript
that you have in front of you
you have a pencil closed at hand so you
can write down any cool new phrases you
hear
maybe you take a few minutes to practice
shadowing or the mimicking of a native
speaker's speech patterns
or maybe you're trying to write the
transcript yourself by transcribing what
you hear
as you hear it however you're processing
the audio you're fully attuned to what
you're hearing
your attention is focused and so your
ability to retain detail
skyrockets what about speaking
well when you speak passively you just
speak you don't try to analyze what
you're saying nor do you wonder
how you can actively improve your main
focus is in
communication and you could care less
about what mistakes you're making
so long as your speaking partner
understands you you also stay rooted
firmly in your comfort zone and avoid
taking risks by using words and phrases
you've never attempted before when you
speak actively you have the additional
goal of trying to process what you're
saying so that you can build upon it
for the future perhaps you're in a
tutoring session and your tutor is
taking notes of your mistakes for later
discussion
perhaps you're recording a monologue on
your phone so you can listen back later
and
judge your performance speaking actively
means pushing your boundaries as well as
filling in gaps
this goes double for conversing actively
which requires asking questions making
comments
and listening intently to what your
speaking partner is saying
when you're speaking proactively yet
again you bring things up to the next
level
for example you might have a recurring
weekly session
scheduled with your favorite online
tutor so that you can give a prepared
speech on a wide variety of topics
or you might start a monthly language
meetup with native speakers
and other enthusiasts so you can
practice conversing with two or more
people on the fly
you could even join a local toastmasters
group dedicated to making public
speeches in your target language
proactive speaking requires forethought
and continually challenging yourself to
speak clearly
and eloquently in a wide variety of
situations
what about passive active and proactive
writing
well for that you'll have to visit my
blog where i've expanded everything i've
shared here with more information
and examples look for the link in the
description box
anyway after all that you might think
that being proactive is the way to go
all day every day not so fast
if only things were so easy i'll agree
with you that the proactive mode is
indeed the most powerful way to learn
but
there's a catch a big catch
you like me and most people around you
are terribly lazy no no no i'm not
accusing you of anything
i'm talking about a biological fact
rooted in the history of our species
once upon a time our ancestors had to
fight
to survive every day they had to eat and
if they wanted to eat they had to hunt
and kill
or be hunted and be killed themselves
if they weren't out engaging in the ever
important task of finding food
our ancestors were resting maybe even
relaxing
why not because they were chronic
procrastinators but because they needed
to save their energy
any ounce of energy wasted at home was
an ounce of energy that could have been
better used
chasing down dinner or avoiding being
something else's dinner
now here in the modern day we may not
need to save our energy to find food but
we're still
hardwired to preserve energy we're not
in life or death situations
and considering there are any apex
predators between you and your
refrigerator that means you're
preserving energy or
in other words being lazy most of the
time this is why a lot of people choose
the path of least resistance when it
comes to learning languages
people love passive short activities
that don't require them to step outside
of their comfort zone
and take any serious risks a couple of
minutes on dual lingo here and there a
few messages sent on whatsapp or
hellotalk and maybe a target language
song or two playing on their iphone
that stuff in and of itself won't take
you very far as always in language
learning the question
is not one of absolutes i'm not saying
that you should do
only proactive learning or that you
should pick just one of the three
to stick with forever in reality the
question
is inclusive you should not favor just
one of the three types of learning but
rather incorporate
all three into your life in different
places and scenarios
you need to find a balance between
active proactive
and passive learning that is dependent
on your energy
attention span motivation and attitude
which can all vary from day to day and
even within a single day
to get you started here's what i propose
make a list
of all the activities you like doing in
your target language
divide them into three main categories
according to each
learning mode passive active and
proactive
then dedicate your freshest most alert
hours of the day
to proactive learning in my experience
this will be roughly 20 percent of your
day
the remaining eighty percent of your day
when you're tired you're commuting or
otherwise busy with something else you
can take part in both active
and passive activities as appropriate if
you'd like to learn more about passive
active and proactive learning as well as
specifics about how to practice writing
in all three modes check the description
box below
for a link to my blog there you'll find
an in-depth article on this topic
as well as an example pdf which explains
how i divide my time
between all three types of learning and
as always thanks for watching
and if you enjoy the video be sure to
like subscribe and hit the notification
bell for lots
more great content to come
[Music]
you